obviously
foreign
thank you
minutes
foreign
thank you
accomplished
foreign
just a second
my kids
before
foreign
is perhaps
Maybe
together
foreign
stop
okay
thank you
foreign
goodness
is
here
guys
foreign
come over there
City
value
thank you
foreign
your idea
information
thank you
foreign
but
all right
next to me
right
here
foreign
okay
thank you
foreign
um
ready
foreign
thank you
stuff
um
foreign
inside
thank you
sir again
information
tonight
thank you
confidence
friends
yes
thank you
foreign
party
the second issues
like
something
afternoon
okay
thank you
foreign
in order to trust America
challenges
Wisconsin
country
thank you
sorry
foreign
destruction
all together
let's go
to provide success
thank you
things
terms of things
foreign
thank you
okay
foreign
thank you
okay
foreign
thanks
straight down
technology
foreign
thank you
numbers
customers
restaurants
to the rest
of Destiny
friends
um